in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Greg
and Celeste are here hey guys how are ya
welcome welcome where you from Boise
Idaho Boise all the way to Nashville
that's a bit of a trip on Thanksgiving
week yeah took a little while fly over I
guess you got family over this way or
something I'm from Kentucky
ah good okay so we make a
transcontinental trip we got to at least
get a double dip out of this right okay
that free scream and see the family good
good so you're here to do your debt-free
scream how much have you paid off so
we've paid off ninety nine thousand
dollars in one year and three months way
to go I like it making what kind of
money we are both software developers
and we make 150 thousand total good for
you
excellent cool great job so what kind of
debt is this or was this so most of it
was student loans we had a car in there
and then we had a small loan to a family
member mm-hmm and that was it so tell me
the story what happened one year and
three months ago well I I had just moved
to Boise and my big brother called me
one day and he asked me if I if I had
heard of Dave Ramsey I said no and I
really look up to my big brother so when
he told me that I just I got all over it
and started looking into you and I just
became just a big part of my life
automatically Wow so I really look up to
him and when he told me that I should do
it I was like okay I just like that okay
whatever he says goes that's cool
now were you guys married at that time
we were not we were engaged
ah okay her brother actually got us a
total money makeover as a gift for a
wedding present
she ran the whole thing on her honeymoon
okay so who Greg Celeste comes in says
my big brother says we've got a I've got
to this Dave Ramsey thing but we're
engaged what did you say I wasn't
totally against it I was kind of
wondering you know how is this gonna go
you know I I was pretty lucky with my
parents they helped me pay for a lot of
my college and I still had some of my
student loan left that we worked on but
I was for it but she had to show me the
way okay all right so you you're not as
not as apt to take big brothers
advice and quickly and easily I got you
you kind of had to it had to be proven
to you yeah okay and so you guys have
been married how long know a year and a
half now
okay alright so basically we come back
from the honeymoon start a Total Money
Makeover then yep and with the combined
debts from the two of you sounds like
most of it was Celeste yes okay we sit
down and we lay out a plan now how did
that first budget meeting sound for
brand-new newlyweds it took forever okay
yeah doing it on paper at first it can
be pretty rough when you're erasing and
drawing and erasing and drawing and
trying to get it all on there they get
smoother as you go okay so you got it
all laid out
you guys didn't fight we don't fight a
lot did you that night no I don't think
so there's got to be a lot of stress
there had to be a lot of a lot of stress
in the air though there was some time
where we were getting maybe halfway
about through I started realizing you
know I I kind of Miss having a little
bit of spending money and so we kind of
squeezed the $50 in there for me every
once in a while okay I got it
okay so as you went further into this
and you're starting to make progress did
you get less intense or more intense as
a couple I got more intense
I was the intense one I really I think I
put a lot of pressure on him okay a lot
of it was my debt and I felt I felt like
we needed to get it knocked out because
I felt accountable for it I told her it
was gonna be okay and we were gonna work
through it um you know it's just gonna
take time you get more intense or less
intense Gregg I got more intense - both
of you - yeah okay all right but she was
already pretty fired up and so she went
like over the lips is what you're saying
yeah okay all right because I got a
feeling Celeste when she gets after it
she gets after it yeah she's like it
when she figures out something she goes
for it that's fine very cool good very
good
and you guys are making really good
money brand-new married how old are you
24 24 years old Megan hundred fifty
grand household income you are killing
it
pink red you have no debt now you're so
weird you are so successful
and so weird every I mean everybody in
your life's got to be looking at you
going proud proud proud aren't like the
other things so yeah your parents are
brother
her parents everybody's got to be
looking at it going dadgum man if Ida
started like that wow you're gonna be
your have so much money it's gonna be
unbelievable it's hard to believe yeah
really I mean you're gonna be able to
give like crazy you're gonna be able to
do stuff you could change your whole
life man and a bunch of other people's
congratulations you too
and get very very well done what was the
hardest part of this for you all I mean
initially just you know we're a newly
married couple and it's getting that
communication down and realizing you
know you're married you guys need to
talk about everything together and
having that monthly budget meeting
brought up a lot of stuff that you know
you might not address until it comes up
the last minute and just being on the
same page then yeah so always a little
friction when that happens yeah what was
the hardest part for you Celeste well I
like I like I'm coffee in the morning I
had to give that up oh okay
ouch now you can drink coffee anywhere
in the world you want to drink coffee
this is pretty cool absolutely amazing
good so you run into other distant
family members maybe that big brother
hasn't had an influence on maybe a
cousin over the holidays and they hear
you guys are paid off ninety nine
thousand dollars in debt and they ask
you that question how did you do that
what do you tell them the keys to
getting out of debt are well I think for
me the biggest thing was I had to have
that moment where I had just had enough
of the student loans mm-hmm and once you
have that moment I once I had that
moment I looked at my students instead
of being annoyed by them it made me mad
mm-hmm and it made me emotional and I
think that's what really brought into
gear for me mm-hmm and also I think us
being an in agreement that this is a
goal that's worth fighting for mm-hmm
getting fired up there's a big part of
it yeah what about you Greg what do you
say the keys are in
same thing that my wife just said but
you've got to have a budget in there I I
am a bad procrastinator and having that
once a month thing before it even starts
to think okay birthday is anything
that's coming up the next month I'll
actually remember it instead of you know
the card always being a few days late
for my mom's birthday you know it's all
the time I like it I like it
so Celeste when you guys sat down that
last night and you I bet you paid that
student loan online didn't you yeah so
you click that button send submit yes
and you were done you were done you were
done how did that feel I don't know I
scramble we clicked it together we
posted it on Facebook you video didn't
put it on as you should and you need to
keep that video and show it to your kids
and your grandkids say this is when your
family tree changed kiddo right here
when we hit Send on that awesome job you
guys are incredible you're rock stars
I'm so proud of you very fun to talk to
you thanks for making a trip down here
Thanksgiving week all right Greg and
Celeste 24 years old a hundred and fifty
thousand dollar income they paid off
ninety nine thousand dollars in the
first one year and three months of their
marriage count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one we're done
how fun are they man that is absolutely
awesome very very very well done